dans le morbihan à belle île en mer en
fin de matinée le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur jean pierre
chevènement est arrivé pour un séjour de
deux semaines du ton séjour de
convalescence celui qui fut hospitalisé
pendant 52 jours et qui restent à une
semaine dans le coma a donc quitté
l'hôpital militaire parisien du val de
grâce pour belle île avec l'intention de
retrouver son ministère place beauvau
avant la fin de l'année reportage de nos
confrères de france 3 bretagne ouest
brigitte beau physique bogeys avec les
commentaires de la vitesse du vent
l'océan tout autour en prime aujourd'hui
il y avait du soleil
jean pierre chevènement enisa son épouse
sont installés à belle île depuis cet
après midi il y aurait du séjour
indéterminée c'est la première sortie
publique du ministre de l'intérieur
depuis son accident
apparemment il n'a rien perdu de son
niveau pourquoi je ne donne pas
d'interview ceci lui donne une interview
naturellement il y aura quelques
malentendus je devrai précisé rectifiez
corriger d'autres répondre je devrais
polémique et je le donne l'interview que
lorsque je serai au maximum de ma force
un fluide et je dis bon alors pour moi
c'est une question de temps il faut que
je me refasse du bifteck parce que j'ai
quand même perdu quelques kilos
et puis que je me fasse surtout
l'hémoglobine voilà sont mes deux
problèmes bélisle est un lieu prisé par
les politiques françois mitterrand y
avait effectué plusieurs c'est faux jean
pierre chevènement lui a loué cette
maison dans un petit air mouche voler
avant de quitter paris hier il a fait
une escale place beauvau ministère pour
un co avec ses collaborateurs expérience
qui vient de traverser son retour d'un
coma que l'on croyait d'irréversible
ce ne sont pas des us et hop j'ai une
bonne chose c'est que il faut savoir
utiliser le temps qui est toujours
compter un bon escient alors je ne force
pas les utiliser le temps qui me reste
est qu'il voit ça tous et aussi bien que
possible que vous avez une date à nous
donner
quant à votre retour éventuel de
personnes il dessine c'est le premier
ministre et puis mon médecin un peu
d'exercice mais surtout beaucoup de
calme c'est tout le programme des
semaines à venir pour jean pierre
chevènement le miracle républicain comme
lui même l'a appelé son retour à la vie
il veut maintenant le savourer à belle
île en mer en plus